California is one of the states with the
highest taxes in all of America.
There's also one of the most expensive
places to live.
If this wasn't bad enough,
the California and government is never
ending risk of bankruptcy with a brutal
amounts of debt and to launch fiscal,
but despite all of this,
California is home to the third richest
and most prosperous region on the
planet.
Yes,
dear viewers,
of course,
I'm talking about the Santa Clara
Valley.
What do you say?
You've never heard of it?
Well,
actually I have because it's better
known by its own official name of
Silicon Valley.
This is the place where companies like
Google,
apple,
and facebook were all born in total.
Thirty nine of the 100 biggest companies
in the entire world have their
headquarters in this place,
but make no mistake.
Silicon valley is not a big metropolis
like New York City or London.
In fact,
the opposite.
Okay.
Straight
cities like Cupertino,
Palo Alto and mountain view have a
little more than 60,000
inhabitants.
Menlo Park where facebook headquarters
are located as a smaller population than
a small town in Kansas,
but in this region,
the average salary,
so policy is $10,000
a month and it's home to many of the
world's largest billionaires.
And if you're wondering,
the answer is no.
There is no silicon mine in the Santa
Clara Valley whatsoever.
In fact,
the name Silicon Valley was coined in
the 19 seventies because this is when
microchips and semiconductors made out
of silicon manufacturer.
Sure.
Don't go looking for any natural
resources in this part of the world
because you won't find any.
So now we come to the real question of
why here?
I mean,
what's so special about this area?
Why not northern California or why not
New York or Chicago or any other place
for that matter?
That was easy to understand why
somewhere like Switzerland is so rich,
they have low taxes and an excellent
political system than Saudi Arabia and
they're rich because they've got oil.
The silicon valley is very different
from those places and it's very
different from other places in America.
For one,
it's got those high taxes we mentioned
and believe me,
the taxes are really,
really high.
For example,
imagine that you a top executive and you
make half a million bucks a year.
If you lived in Texas,
you'd pay around 32 percent in income
tax.
Yeah.
However,
in California you would pay 42 percent.
As you can see,
the difference is meaningful.
So again,
why Silicon Valley and North Texas or
Delaware or Nevada,
what makes this region quite so special
for startup,
and even more importantly than that,
well,
what is a start up and how is created
well in today's we're going to answer
all of those questions,
but before we do,
let's have a look back at the history.
The trader is there all times in history
when several coincidences happen all at
once and this,
this is the miracle of cylinder.
Our story starts in the year 1956 with a
company called Shockley semiconductor
lab.
They were the first company in the
valley to manufacturers silicon based
micro jets.
Their offices were in a little village
with no more than 7,000
inhabitants.
This was a village called mountain view
located on the outskirts of San
Francisco.
Back then,
nobody talked about silicon valley,
but of course the San Francisco
Peninsula was one of the tech capitals
of America night.
It's actually the radon is used by the
army were manufactured by a company that
you might have heard of,
Hewlett Packard.
Further,
Stanford University generated skilled
professionals ready to work in rocket
science,
but let's get back to art.
Friends are shopping.
They were the most advanced company in
their fields and perhaps this company
could have gone very,
very far.
Bonds,
they had a big problem,
apparently people in the company who
felt that their boss was a bit of a
Dick,
and so what happens?
Well,
one day,
eight of the youngest work isn't.
The company went to Mr Shockley his
office and essentially said Shockley,
you could take your stupid ass company
and stick it up your ass.
We're the ones who designed your
technology.
We're the brains of this business,
so we're going to get outta here,
start our own business and kick ass
without you.
These eight,
and then became known as the traitorous
eight.
Their average age was 30,
they had no money whatsoever and they
wanted to start a state of the art
technology company that required a lot
of investments and you might be thinking
now,
well,
which banks lend the money and the
answer to that is absolutely not.
However,
pay attention here because this was the
beginning of something really,
really big in 1959,
the first venture capital funded
company.
It was born,
but hold on a second year because I do
want to explain what that actually
means.
You have an idea since the beginning of
capitalism,
there have been people with money
willing to partner with people who had
ideas and together they started
companies.
Nonetheless.
After World War Two,
lots of soldiers came home from the
battlefields and one out of every two
veterans they wanted to start a company
and
all of a sudden there was a spike in
demand for financing.
This is why many of the people with
money started rethinking the way that
businesses use to work.
For instance,
there's Laurance Rockefeller from the
famous Rockefeller family.
This man had something more than lots of
money.
He also knew other people who had money,
so essentially one day in 1959,
he called them all up and said,
listen up ditch chops,
put down your champagne glasses and your
caviar for a second,
the shy and your monocle and pay
attention because I just found eight
guys in California who have a great
business idea that very,
very clever and they want to develop
some weird stuff with lots of
technology.
It's got silicone and other things I
don't understand,
but if you fancy this idea,
give me your money invested in said
business,
and if it all goes well,
will become even richer than we are now.
Pip,
pip,
and say it wasn't was sad,
so it was done.
This is how in 1959,
the traitorous eight from Silicon Valley
started fairchild semiconductors with
the money from Rockefeller and his
billionaire friends.
This was the first time.
It wasn't just one rich dude investing,
but a collective society of rich dudes
instead,
and this.
This is how the first venture capital
fund called Venn rock associated was
born,
and guess where they have their
headquarters.
Of course,
that's Palo Alto.
This was silicon,
so this was a really risky idea and
that's why these funds are call of
venture capital funds.
I mean,
if you put your money into a big company
like Coca Cola,
you'll lose or win a little bit of
money,
but it's really hard to go fully
bankrupt nonetheless,
giving money to a guy with nothing but
an idea that's a pretty risky Joel.
So well,
what's the advantage?
Then?
Of course it's that if it goes right,
you get stupidly rich and so then we
have to answer the question,
well,
what's the secret of success?
Of course you do want to invest in lots
of different companies at the same time.
You need just one out of 10 to be
successful to make it worthwhile.
And the truth is that Rockefeller and
his other fellows made a hell of an
investment.
Actually,
the company still exists today and has
offices all over the world,
and so what happens when one person gets
stupidly rich by doing something?
Well,
a lot of copycats spring up out of the
blue trying to do the same thing by the
year.
Nineteen 82.
There were already 12 vc funds in
silicon valley,
their philosophy,
it was simple,
get private money from investors,
pension plans,
and of course all those rich dudes and
then a team of specialized professionals
meet entrepreneurs and startups looking
for good ideas.
In summary,
silicon valley has an old car of guys
who study at Stanford.
Clever guys.
You study somewhere else,
but eventually emigrated till the
valley.
A network of companies that make it easy
to start any business.
Of course,
a ton of money.
All right.
All right,
so this all sounds pretty cool,
but what does a Silicon Valley company
actually look like?
How does this startup system and VC
funds actually work?
Well,
let's have a look.
Shall We?
Silicon Valley way.
I know I know the word stars.
I'm has already become another buzzword
that stupid people used to sound
smarter.
So then.
Well,
what is the difference between a normal
company and a startup?
Well,
here's a good definition.
It is a company designed to grow fast.
Paul Graham,
founder of Yahoo Store and venture
capital investor.
All right,
so now I can probably guess what you're
thinking.
I mean,
company is designed to grow fast.
Well actually no,
just look at Ikea is a good example.
Ikea is one of the most successful
companies of all time,
but his main principles since the
beginning has been to grow only with its
own funds.
No debt from banks or hedge fund
that unlike other companies,
Ikea took a long time to grow,
but he was healthy,
consistent growth.
So now the question still remains.
What is a startup?
Well,
facebook would be a great example here.
Why?
First of all,
because it's a scalable business.
This means it doesn't matter if they
have one or a million uses.
The spending is almost the same,
but not only that.
Facebook is the perfect example of what
we know as the startup financing cycle
and pay attention here because this.
This is really key in understanding how
silicon valley
wow
first step is what we know as the valley
of death.
Why is it called this?
Well,
because this is the stage when most
projects don't survive.
In the case of facebook,
we have our friends,
Mark Zuckerberg and Edwardo Savrin who
had a great business idea,
but an idea by itself has little or no
use.
You have to execute on it.
So these new friends,
they put down money out of their own
pockets to launch their first prototype,
which was the facebook.com
and well,
you know the rest of the story.
Suddenly all of the students,
Harvard University,
they had an account next stage.
Well that was to become a serious
company with work as officers and other
important stuff like that and valeant
bought and stuff.
You need money as well.
Did they have any money?
Well,
no.
So what did they do while they went to
silicon valley and they met this guy at
that you see here,
his name is Peter
and
listen up here because this is the first
difference between the valley and the
rest of the world.
He's a teal is what we know as an angel
investor.
He's a guy with a lot of money and he's
willing to invest in companies that are
still in this valley of death at this
moment,
2004.
Facebook was an idea with a lot of
potential,
but almost no profit investment.
It was so risky that no bank woodlands
any money to them.
So instead Peter Teal,
but $500,000
into facebook with this,
he was buying 10 percent of the company
and now you might be wondering,
well,
why just 10 percent at the end of the
day?
Back then facebook,
it wasn't worth anything with so much
money invested.
Peter Teal could have demanded a bigger
share of the company and to be fair,
that is absolutely true if they were
located somewhere like Alabama.
So they began offering competing good
conditions to the entrepreneur nurse.
So if he asks for too many shares of the
company is knocking bag and sovereign
would just have gone to somebody else.
Don't worry there.
Everybody.
Peter Thiel is still extraordinarily
rich.
All right,
so you're probably beginning to
understand why it's a good idea to start
companies yet,
but hold on a minute because you ain't
seen nothing yet with all million
dollars,
facebook's founders could start building
something big,
something that could be sold to the mass
market.
Really,
this is the moment when a company proves
itself successful or not.
The moment when they survive the valley
of death,
while they don't.
If facebook was founded in Alabama,
they would have probably stopped here.
They had a product it worked out and the
money to live on and the story,
but remember this is a startup and it's
goal is to grow as fast as it possibly
can.
This is where those vc funds came into
the shop.
We're not talking about a Peter Teal guy
with a lot of money here.
We're talking about companies with even
more money and the team of advisors.
This is important because in many cases
vc funders can make vital decisions in
the company and even tell the founders
how they have to design their corporate
structure,
who they can partner with or even how
and when to expand internationally.
All right,
so coming back to our facebook story,
in the year 2005,
a vc fund called Excel partners put 12
point $7,000,000
into facebook with this.
They owned 13 percent of the company.
As an aside,
if you remember Peter Teal bought 10
percent of facebook with half a million
dollars and the less excel partners
subsequently paid 12 point $7,000,000
for 13 percent of the company.
If you do the math,
you see that from one day to the next,
facebook is now valued at $98 million
dollars.
In other words,
in just one year Peter teals investment
increased by 2000 percent.
Pretty impressive,
right?
But again,
hold on because yes,
still haven't seen anything yet.
This ansel partners investment is what
we call a series a investments.
And if there's a series a,
it's because later we have a series B,
series c.
alright,
so in the case of facebook,
the series c funding was Microsoft.
He paid $240,000,000
in 2007 for this $240,000,000.
They were getting just one point six
percent of facebook,
so let's return to our maths because
it's pretty mind blowing.
Facebook is now valued at
$15,000,000,000.
This means that that 10 percent,
the Pto ball for half a million dollars
is now worth 300 percent more.
Oh,
alright.
So this means that if you regular viewer
had invested just a hundred dollars in
facebook in the year 2004,
you'd now have enough money to buy a
waterfront house with a swimming pool
and a mini golf course.
All right,
so hold on a moment because at this
point you might be wondering,
well hold on a second.
Simon,
was facebook actually worth
$15,000,000,000
at that moment?
Did they really make enough money to
that crazy $240,000,000
investments?
Well,
no,
but you see by investing all that money,
you get lots and lots of things,
things that sooner or later what ends up
making you a profit and this,
this is when we get to the final stage
of a startup,
but we sell it to a big company or do we
go public?
Facebook?
They decided to enter the stock market,
but many other startups will typically
be sold to big multinational company.
I pull back exam in $400,000,000
and yes,
I know what you are going to tell me.
All right Simon,
this sounds really,
really good,
but I just don't believe it's that easy
and why you'd be absolutely Ryan's
because nine out of 10 startups fail,
but importantly,
you just need one to succeed to make a
lot of people crazy,
crazy,
rich.
This is why the goal of so many
politicians now is to make that own
silicon valley
white Bernadine silicon alley is
Europe's new silicon,
the Mexicans,
silicon
volume
Africa near Silicon Valley's.
Yep.
Everybody wants to have their own
silicon valley in their own back yard.
Well,
everybody except for those people who
actually lived in silicon
lit are abandoning silicon valley in
droves,
but that is something we're going to
actually talk about in our next video.
Meanwhile,
the big question is this,
do you think we can replicate the
silicon valley model in other countries?
While please do leave your answer in the
comments section below.
Also,
don't forget to Jack our reconsider
media,
don't call them,
they're the podcast.
They provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
And remember we published brand new
videos every week,
so subscribe and hit that little button
so you won't miss any posts.
And if you liked this video,
give us a thumbs up.
As always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice,
don't forget to check out the reconsider
podcast@reconsidermedia.com.
We consider it as a podcast that
challenges you to reconsider your views
by providing context,
but we don't do the thing.